[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur ce qu'on appelle à l'origine sont
nombreux et sont généralement très
tranchées de la reprise à lille 2 1
n'est pas seulement parce que les jeunes
ministres avant les chiffres des cdc
effet sous le sens 3 lui qui est la cgt
s'est chargé de parler jeudi par se
mettre en scène cette arme en effet un
deuxième est une fiction un genre 2005
un titre du journal le monde était vivre
avec 400 mo ce qui est totalement
impossible parce que si vous pensez au
nombre de mots que constitue je me moi
le bonnet quant à l'ossature etc
c'est impossible de ne disposer que de
quatre chambres
n'empêche que c'était dans le très
sérieux journal troisième rubrique tout
aussi tranchée il s'agit d'une
expression riche et là on voit fleurir
des adjectifs comme créatif politique
images et inventif etc
on peut se demander pourquoi des façons
de parler apparaissent aussi
caractéristique et surtout aussi quoi la
plupart des gens immédiatement
identifiable c'est à dire que la plupart
des gens disent reconnaître à tous les
coups d'un la langue des jeunes c'est
pour explorer
cette liste comme nous avons constitué
un vaste corpus autour d'une équipe n'en
croise un vaste corpus de la zone dont
la première constatation et un débit de
paroles particulièrement appuyé vous
donner un exemple une coupole non
périssables ou je prendrai toutes
propres et l'époque dérive
ils m'appellent pour pouvoir pour
expliquer comment rentrer en fermant
tous les plans durant cette coupe est
habitué je suppose que vous n'avez pas
compris grand chose il couve elle danse
avec les loups
tu vois le prix avec bottes qui arrivent
ils m'appellent vous rendez vous
rappeler comment en plus d'en faire mon
goût les flambeurs en fait tous habitués
de retour en un extrait de 9 secondes
on a ici 72 mots ce qui fait une moyenne
à peu près de 450 mots par minute ce qui
est exceptionnellement rapide toutes les
langues change toutes les langues ont
toujours changer et une certitude qu'on
peut avoir ce que on ne parle plus
aujourd'hui comme on parlait au moyen
âge ni comme on parlait au xviie siècle
ni même comme on parlait il y a un
siècle
la question qu'on peut se poser enfin
qui concerne l'ensemble de l'après midi
c est ce que les jeunes sont les
principaux artisans du changement de la
lande
tout d'abord il faut savoir de quel
jeune on parle parce qu il y a des
jeunes qui ne sont pas jeunes
et il y à des jeunes qui ne parle pas un
jeune il ne s'agit donc pas d'une
question de démographie et le traitement
sociologique pourrait-on dire sauver le
consul à la d1 perdu et de notre corpus
pierre qui répond à une question qui lui
est posée par l'enquêtrice ana vous
voyez donc
anna se demande si les jeunes de plus de
40 ans enfin les grands de plus de 40
ans peuvent parler la langue des jeunes
est la réponse que va faire pierre ses
choeurs les jeunes qui traînent
oui et même aussi d'ailleurs les tout
petits
s'ils traînent dans les allées et
insipide
ils peuvent parler de la même manière on
en conclut que la langue des jeunes est
une question de style de lits et est une
question de plus ou moins grande
proximité avec la culture des rues tous
les niveaux de la langue s'avère
concernés par la langue des jeunes mais
certains plus que d'autres et que de
lexique avec trois phénomènes lexicaux
qui sont à mentionner largo les emprunts
et les procédés ou manipulation de mots
existants commençons par largo la
question de l'argot en français remonte
très très loin du moins remonte très
loin quand on en a des attestations par
ce code ce sont des termes qui se
conservent extrêmement peu largo qui est
essentiellement une forme orale de
langue ne sera pas conservé ou ne sera
que très peu concernée ou ne sera
conservé que par hasard
donc on en a très peu d'attestation
néanmoins on a une attestation bajaur
cas
exemple grâce au poète françois vision
qui était à la fois poète et mauvais
garçon et qui a écrit plusieurs poèmes
en argot donc on sait que c'était déjà
vivant à une époque quand même assez
ancienne puisqu'il s'agit de la fin du
moyen âge les jeunes sont souvent
persuadés d'être les inventeurs de leurs
maux c'est à dire qu'au lieu de voir une
ancienneté très profonde
il croit au contraire avoir tout inventé
on en a l'exemple de sa mur qui dit
c'est pas du verlan tu vois mais je
crois oseille ses blagues en fait
oz est un très vieux mots argotiques et
sanaa la qualité de black
même chose pour d'aronde aaron les
darons perm aujourd'hui extrêmement
courant en fait on s'aperçoit que
d'aaron est attestée déjà au xviie
siècle au xviie siècle avec un sens
légèrement différent du sens actuel
puisqu'il signifie m
mais dès le 18e il prend le sens actuel
d'un père ce sont les premières
attestations ça ne veut pas dire que ça
n'existait pas avant
venons en aux emprunts là aussi toutes
les langues empreinte le français comme
les autres c'est normal mais les
domaines d'emprunt et les langues
ok là on emprunte se modifier au cours
du temps en particulier grâce aux
échanges qui peuvent prendre place avec
telle ou telle population les emprunts
al arab dont on trouve
de grandes exemple aujourd'hui les
exemples nombreux surtout les emprunts à
l'arabe remonte au moyen-age simplement
les domaines auxquels le moyen-âge à
emprunter à l'arabe sont particuliers
par exemple le vocabulaire des sciences
est extrêmement fourni en mots arabes
comme zéro ou chiffres tout simplement
parce que la science arabe était en
avance par rapport à la science
européenne
un autre domaine d'emprunt et est
constitué par le vocabulaire courant
par exemple un mot comme jupe ou sucre
le sucre c'est évidemment le mot est
venue en même temps que la spécialité et
puis là la colonisation en particulier
de l'algérie donc à partir de 1830 a
joué un grand rôle et des mots comme
kawa ou toubib ont transité par largo
militaire avant de venir s'implanter en
france mais en tout cas c'est une
histoire déjà relativement ancienne les
emprunts d'aujourd'hui sont assez
nettement différent puisqu'il s'agit
plutôt de mots des marges par exemple
indiqué les trois exemples de craps
d'avoir aura là mais il y en a plein
d'autres dans le corpus d'ailleurs nous
avons rencontré 285 mo différents il
s'agit pas d'occuper ans il s'agit de
mots 285 mo différents venus de l'arabe
cependant seuls une vingtaine de ses 285
mo sont d'une grande fréquence comme
wesh qui ou sun et on les trouve chez la
plupart des locuteurs du corpus qui ne
sont pas tous
d'origine maghrébine et on trouve même
chez des locuteurs qui n'ont rien à voir
ni avec la maghribi li té ni avec la
religion musulmane on trouve
l'expression wallah qui signifie je le
jure par allart en entrant en français
les mots ont souvent changé de chance
comme par exemple le mot sonne en arabe
signifiait vena il ya un vague rapport
avec le sens actuel de ce mais il est
quand même relativement à il s'avère que
aujourd'hui la la pénétration de mots
arabes
on ne peut pas dire ce qui se passera à
l'avenir mais on a là des signes certain
que cette pénétration de l'arabe s'est
considérablement accélérée depuis
quelques années enfin ma troisième et
dernière rubrique les procédés le
français est une langue particulièrement
riche en procédés qui reviennent
périodiquement à la mode le plus répandu
de cesser de procéder en tout cas
aujourd'hui est le verlan qui là aussi
mais pas nouveauté puisque où j'en avons
des attestations avec ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure pour la gauche est
toujours d'actualité
des attestations rare vu les conditions
de conservation mais il est attesté en
tout cas dès le xviiie siècle
aujourd'hui les jeunes en sont
incontestablement les principaux usagers
et il a été considérablement revitaliser
on ne sait pas trop pourquoi on ne sait
pas analysé
pourquoi ni comment comment s'est passée
par quels canaux s'est passé il est
considérablement revitaliser dans les
années 60 80 et en voilà quelques
exemples meuf cov goyri vénère tej a
donc gosses beau certains de ces mots
sont entrés dans les dictionnaires en
particulier oeuf meuf comme coffe ou
bear se trouve dans le petit larousse
il est intéressant de noter que ces mots
nouveaux n'ont pas toujours conservé le
même sens que l'original et à ce titre
il constitue un véritable enrichissement
de la langue puisque par exemple ripoux
ne signifie pas exactement la même chose
que pour y jamais vous dirais qu'il ya
des légumes bricout dans votre
frigidaire le verlan s'avère assez
spécifique à la région parisienne on en
trouve dans des lieux comme marseille
bordeaux montréal mais il est beaucoup
moins créatif qu'en région parisienne et
il ressemble plutôt à la vingtaine de
mots que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
c'est à dire des mots qu'on trouve
partout chez tout le monde
ritualisé vous pourrez venir d'une
certaine façon
bien qu'il y ait aujourd'hui semble-t-il
en région parisienne un certain
ralentissement
un autre procédé à d'autres procédés
sont les trente rotations qui peuvent
troquer le début du mot ou leur faim
alors des 30 cassions du début du mot
zik pour musique ska rien pour whisky de
façon curieuse d'ailleurs parce que en
anglais vous qui me se prononcent
sûrement pas buscail tiag leur
contrôleur ou bien croque à sion de la
fin mu pour musulmans et moore
pour mouvement tous a produit beaucoup
de liberté de créativité dans les
croisements
par exemple un mot comme carrie robien
américain mais après la troc à sion
ricains vous avez en plus une
verbalisation touche y vient de shit
donc emprunt à l'anglais plus vers la
nisation on aurait pu multiplier ici des
exemples et je vais vous donner un
exemple de ce corps
comme la plupart des locuteurs mais
c'est parfaitement normal parce qu on ne
peut pas s'interroger sur l'origine des
mots qu'on emploie en permanence comme
la plupart des locuteurs les jeunes ne
savent pas toujours de quoi il s'agit et
voilà un exemple plus jeune samir
enregistré par l'enquêteur n'a cher et
samir qui se dit lui-même algériens
montrent à quel point ils ignorent
l'arabe le rhum
l'as rome l'as rome l'as rome 11 heures
wen en arabe mais le ballon est donc
finalement revenons à notre question
initiale qu'est ce que les jeunes font
avec la langue
alors ils manifestent incontestablement
des phénomène fréquent
et nombreux cependant on peut se
demander si ces phénomènes sont si ils
sont novateurs dans leur utilisation
mais dans leur schéma même ils ne sont
pas particulièrement novateur parce que
presque tous ses fonctionnements sont
déjà là dans la langue est depuis
longtemps ce qu'on peut résumer avec la
phrase nul les maîtres de la langue et
le dernier mot c'est pour dire que tous
les jeunes du monde indoor avec la
langue in ore dans la limite de ce que
j'ai indiqué des schémas déjà existants
les jeunes hommes et on peut se demander
pourquoi est ce qu'ils innovent et
finalement la réponse serait
certainement que la langue constitue
l'un des plus forts marqueurs d'identité
qui soit et c'est la paix sont donc les
jeunes ont la possibilité de se faire
une place dans un monde qui ne leur
laisse pas toujours énormément de place